[Music]
and sharkbite selfie news oh this is
real I thought it was a joke submitted
by Brisbane Brisbane and mr. grant
Waddell was attacked by a shark while
swimming in the Bahamas was this a real
picture that was photoshopped it's real
in this person you're ashy and then
they're like that that's the first thing
they could think of us taking she got
beat up she's alive okay I thought I'd
be a dude we can make now I don't feel
so bad I don't know about taking a
selfie want to see so she saw the shark
coming is she was like it's worth it all
right so this model her name is Katrina
she's 19 years old and she's also a
nursing student this is what she looks
like you got to do two jobs these days
as a model so her boyfriend was taking
photos of her when she felt like all
these nurse nurse or the shark come from
she-she's a nursing studio a nurse
sharks God's money and nurse sharks are
supposed to be very docile exactly
that's the reason why she went in
because she heard that they're super
super very nice yeah they're really nice
they don't do anything so she took this
photo oh yeah a lot of people take
photos with nurse sharks yeah some clear
as [ __ ] water cuffs beautiful sorry
dude I see a shark that [ __ ] big with
fins and [ __ ] I'm not in there
I'm not in there when a lot of sharks
get together like that it looks like
eels from here looks like a bunch of
rocks oh yeah see like a pan you know
what that's what she gets for listening
to [ __ ] Discovery Channel that's what
you exactly Discovery Channel saying
they're more scared of you than you are
the how the [ __ ] do you know did you
ever talk to a [ __ ] shark [ __ ] the
[ __ ] exactly they're not that scared if
they're it's like how monkeys are using
tools right now in the Amazon forest
okay did you hear about that [ __ ] we
don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] about these
animals do we don't know what to really
do they're evolving kill them all kill
them all before they kill us they're
like they're all observant they're in
the Stone Age now that is frightening
yeah dude what happens when they get to
the Bronze Age brother yeah
you're a monkey with a [ __ ] smelter
and like making a [ __ ] clay morsel
Planet of the Apes is gone we gotta get
him now it's all [ __ ] like gorilla
the jungle just turns right here they
say there's mouths like whoa that's too
real right and he rolled his own that's
when I'm like no we're not playing games
anymore humans isn't there videos of
smoking monkeys hell yeah oh the best
videos I miss it roll it themselves is
what these do [ __ ] that actually make me
cry laughing like nothing else is
monkeys smoking cigarettes there's
nothing funnier to me in the entire
world then a monkey walking upright with
the cigarette in his mouth hey I [ __ ]
love it it looks like a toddler smoking
and there ends people throw that into
the zoo yeah and the monkey picks it up
cause they mimic people how how they see
people do you know what's [ __ ]
fronting though like when you see those
videos of those not trained aids but
highly intelligent Apes and they learn
how to sign and [ __ ] but you just see I
saw a video mr. Rogers talking to one
and all I could think about is that
man's face is gonna get ripped off I
always think of that right cuz she
wanted to hug for mr. Rogers she loved
mr. Rogers so much but he can't say no
he have to hug her anyway right because
the gorilla was like this he can't be
like no thank you
the gorilla would have smashed his
[ __ ] face it you talk about Coco the
gorilla
it is Coco I figure so Coco just died Oh
Coco who's been around for a long long
time
Coco just passed away oh yeah - glad we
couldn't do that one do we do we have a
picture of the of the bite yes so right
when she's doing all right which is
about right so it's right when she's
doing that the next photo is the actual
bite literally what she just emphasized
I'm emphasized because I want to make
sure just wait you could have literally
confirmed what she went like this
audience didn't watch a show called
interrupting - yeah like so a shark came
near her arm bit it she put her arm up
because she didn't want to attract more
sharks with her blood will get out the
water why is the boyfriend just keep
snapping pictures oh yeah that is the
funny part okay baby yep keep bleeding
but the blows are great photos by the
way and then after that's not the oh
that's nothing
oh it's probably they probably thought
it was like a fish or something that's
harder than that like a bite it looks
like she hit it wrong
it looks like an Indian right yeah
that's nothing she faked it man I
thought half of her body was gonna be
yeah like gone well I thought a chunk of
her arm would be missing her body would
be gone yeah from a shark bite yeah
that's that's nothing sure that's
nothing so nurse sharks are friendly
yeah they don't do [ __ ] I was a kiss
TIFF I'm sorry I disappointed you guys
don't know vacations we want to talk
about Koko TIFF yeah you monster koko
passed away hope that's cool you who has
the white haired fox that takes care of
Coco the lady oh yeah oh there's no
ladies I'm not ashamed Goodall oh wow
wait but she lived she lives with
primates for like a long time I met you
she bought some gorillas too she's all
like I need to [ __ ] be a part of the
pack so Coco though watched are you
telling me that she watched a bunch of
Mister Rogers and then when she saw mr.
Rogers she's like I want a hug yeah I'm
not sure if it was Coco specifically Bob
would you say it for the sake of this
article it was but she was a huge fan of
mr. Rogers and wanted to meet mr. that's
the most touching [ __ ] I've ever heard
in my life
you look at that [ __ ] it's crazy talking
to [ __ ] Coco like oh is this what you
want to show me he's like aren't you
just the sweetest little monkey
it is Coco see Wow
look at Coco looking at mr. Rogers man
this [ __ ] real do you need a
friend I wonder if she knows the
difference between this is TV not a man
inside a window I know my cat that could
literally tear him in half the only way
I would take a picture with the gorillas
is before I even get that close like I
have a knife and I have it at its belly
it wouldn't matter they were still rip
you in half before you even get the
killer really good knife they grab your
wrist in the night falls out of your
hand bro if a monkey if a gorilla ask me
for a hug I'll be like I've been waiting
for this all my life I've been waiting
but I don't wanna well in that
[ __ ] I would hunt Coco cuz I
believe the meme of Coco it's cold I'm
afraid of me meeting a gorilla and the
gorilla likes me too much and I can't
leave oh look at this Robin Williams
she was tickling him oh well she loved
Mork and Mindy - that's all right
what a nice girl well if Robin Williams
did it didn't he he was actually funny
odds awesome see now we're talking about
Cooper you happy yeah I am I know you
don't tell me Katara Coco family
Robin Williams is a genius yes Bart
barely watched mrs. Doubtfire don't fire
me too much and I loved it I was crying
us about fire patch Adams all patch I
was another good one I think hook is my
favorite yeah mrs. Doubtfire I think the
first thing I watched of him
dude the amount of hair on that man was
unreal it was nuts he could take off his
shirt and Coco wouldn't recognize who he
is he's been then the ape
did you see the footage of him swimming
with the dolphins no because he has so
much doesn't he loved animals he was he
did a there's a documentary of him
swimming in dolphins it means so much
hair coming off of him and he like
literally took dolphins up out of the
water with him he's like a sponge you're
like [ __ ] flipping like that off of
his body yeah he was like a fisherman's
net oh yeah
newse insane it's krill and [ __ ]
everything stuck in there yeah unreal
Harry is [ __ ] this is here would like
stick out like from him like this oh you
know there's a shark in Hawaii and it's
actually one of the sharks that bike
called a tiger shark
but people swim with them so they're
used to people swimming with this one
particular one that they do little
swimming with partiers no this one I
mean it's tiger sharks are the ones that
always by humans but they always bite
humans by accident because if the water
is murky they think oh mr. seal but when
the water is clear though I don't know
why this one they always swim with and
you could get tours and go swim with
this whatever friendly without a Kate
without a cage with the cage it was
scary but it would eat you alive you are
you aren't a moose boost to a shot and
good and you know what you're won by two
you're a one bite
you know one bite or I'm [ __ ] bite oh
it's Mack no you're not a snack that
should be a huge bag of chips yeah you
are literally the crumbs at the end of
Julia's attack
Julie is a snack julia is like a chicken
nugget to these guys that's a dart but
anyway yeah so this girl is okay as you
guys could see yeah that's really
upsetting though I want her to be hurt a
little more to the story
yeah you want the pictures to match the
story didn't want her to be harmed
yeah we just expected her to be and if I
wonder if she was gonna be missing a
chunk out of her leg like lip like no
joke yesterday during Muay Thai
I literally tore the bottom of my skin
and it was way looks way worse than that
on my foot and no sharks were involved
Fox does that happening you habits when
you kick cuz you have to eat your toe
for balance and then you just keep doing
it over and over and over
it happens if you don't have a callus
it'll have no I'm not by slowly do
things oh oh oh my David just goes on he
probably had his feet in those [ __ ]
finger shoes for like the past year and
then one day he's like you know what
how much is called barefoot for three
hours straight so that's probably what
happened it was on a mat back
[Music]
[Applause]